Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Oh! Oh mein Gott!
Der erste Crash hatte ich schon eben.
Ich bin übrigens nicht farbenblind, auch wenn es jemand gefragt hat gerade.
Aber es gibt ja Games, wo man Vorteile hat, wenn man das Setting auf farbenblind stellt.
Oh, ich wusste gar nicht, dass man bei farbenblind einen Punkt im Auge hat.
Hier lernt man noch was.
Beta-Crash, das sind 2k17, 0.
Tag, wir wollen aber nicht Fullscreen, wir wollen eigentlich Borderless haben.
Ich kann nicht so lange spielen.
Ich spiele heute Abend wieder eine Runde Dungeons & Dragons.
So richtig mit Leuten und sowas.
Geht um 18 Uhr los, deswegen kann ich jetzt nur relativ kurz stremen, dann muss ich noch was futtern.
Enable DirectX 12.
Wie ist eigentlich die Lautstärke vom Game? Meint ihr, das passt so?
Mit Leuten, ja, ja, ne?
Mit Leuten, es gibt Sachen, die hätte ich selbst nicht für möglich gehalten.
So, Vertical Sync braucht kein Mensch.
Moment, warum kann ich mal...
Warum kann ich Field of View nicht ändern?
Warum?
Warum kann ich das Field of View nicht ändern?
Soll ich den installieren gleich wieder?
55 FOF, seid ihr von allen guten Geistern verlassen da ist, oder was?
FOF 55.
PC Master Race.
Ich will das FOF ändern.
Musste in den Settings Files machen.
Geht das wirklich über die Settings Files? Muss ich jetzt mal nachgucken.
Battlefront Settings FOF.
Das müssen wir machen. Ich gehe mit dem FOF von 55 kann ich nicht spielen.
Ich gucke jetzt mal, ob ich eine Konfig-Datei finde von dem Game.
Settings.
Profile Options, ja.
Anscheinend...
Anscheinend gibt es da eine Settings-Datei.
Die Spinery.
Wo kann man das FOF einstellen?
Ich spiele garantiert nicht mit einem FOF von...
...von 55.
Moin, Patrick.
Ah, hier ist es.
Field.
Field of View ist eins.
Okay, da muss ich jetzt erstmal Guide gucken, wie man das FOF einstellt.
Muss FOF einstellen.
You can change the default FOF.
Use the FOF Calculator.
What?
Okay, ein FOF von 95 ist angeblich 1,723043.
Es ist sehr intuitiv zu benutzen. Machen wir das Game nochmal aus.
Und schreiben...
...in die Options...
...Field of View schreiben wir...
...dann die Zahl rein, okay.
Und dann starten wir das Game nochmal und hoffen, dass das FOF wieder höher ist.
Wenn das FOF nicht höher ist, mache ich wieder aus.
Moin, Chosen.
Ah, 55er FOF, das halte ich dann aus.
Boah, 2000 FPS.
2K.
2K FPS.
Okay.
So, ist das FOF jetzt besser?
Äh.
Okay.
Entweder habe ich das FOF jetzt kaputt gemacht oder es ist gut.
Brightness 75 oder Brightness 70 bestimmt ganz gut.
Ein bisschen weniger Video-Settings, hä?
EA-Account.
What?
No.
Nichts gibt's.
Gameplay.
Third-Person OP.
Zumindest war das im ersten Teil OP, Third-Person.
Es wird im zweiten Teil wieder OP sein.
Blah, was sonst?
Keine Ahnung.
Audio, Master, Volume.
Oh, gibt's Voip?
Also gibt's In-Game-Voice-Chat?
Hm.
Was zum Teufel ist ein Han-Stereo?
Was nehme ich für Kopfhörer?
Wir nehmen Auto.
Ah, okay.
Headphone.
Back.
Ich zocke Borderless, dass das Game ab raus tappen nicht abkackt, weil das hatte ich eben auch schon mal.
Okay.
Ach, Moment.
Man kann ja sogar noch runterscrollen, Lull.
Motionplur.
Motionplur wollen wir gar nicht.
Motionplur ist das Schlimmste, was es gibt.
Okay.
Wir lassen die Settings mal auf Auto und gucken mal, wie das sich so spielt.
Der erste Teil lief ja ziemlich gut.
So.
Galactic Assault.
Ich habe übrigens weder großartige Ahnung von Star...
Das sollte alles sagen, ich muss den Satz gar nicht beenden.
Aber weder Ahnung von Star Wars noch von Battlefront, weil das erste Game habe ich später gespielt,
hat mir gedacht, was ein fragwürdiges Casual Game.
Starfighter Assault spielen wir nicht.
Im Prinzip kann man anscheinend bloß Galactic Assault spielen, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Okay.
Mal gucken, wie das Game läuft.
Moin, Ag...
Akenas.
Ich bin heute Morgen um 4.45 Uhr aufgestanden.
Strike kann ich auch spielen.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen...
Ich habe überhaupt gar keine Ahnung, ich habe null informiert von dem Game.
Okay.
Das ist Sniper.
Das ist...
Was wie Engineer würde ich sagen.
Das ist sowas wie Support.
Das ist Assault.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an, wie der ganze Krampf funktioniert.
Okay, was Strike ist, muss man...
Okay, ich spiele alle Assault.
Das ist vielleicht die taktisch geschickte Variante.
Uweee!
Das Game läuft gut.
Alter, guckt euch das mal an!
Guckt euch das mal an!
Was?
Das Foff ist fast schon ein bisschen hoch, ne?
Wie gut das Game aussieht?
Wie gut das Game läuft?
RIP, Kott.
Wobei, nicht wirklich.
Die Games sind ziemlich unterschiedlich, ne?
Aber so, so mal, so mal hier, ne?
Kott struggled hier mit seinen 100 FPS.
Auf, auf Mittel.
Was ist denn das?
Lichter.
Wo sind hier Gegner?
Null.
Warte!
Was ist das jetzt gewesen?
Genji mains.
Gengu main, by the way.
Schreckt.
Ähm.
Ähm, warum gibt es überhaupt jetzt einen Abschnitt der Map?
Pssst.
Ich habe eigentlich keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wir können eigentlich nicht weiter reisen.
Okay, ah es gibt Active Reload.
Sowas wie in Giswo.
Alter, ins Giswo.
Der Held sieht sehr fair aus, muss ich sagen.
Sehr fair.
Was übrigens?
Granate, was Granate werfen, Alter?
was gerade war
ok helden scheinen wir sehr färd zu sein das sieht man schon
wie ist denn moment die kontrolzeit mal kontrolkuh ist granada
rekt
ok das gelb läuft in ultra settings gut
sebaro ne aber heute war ich früher da deswegen bin ich schon um 11.45
weg
hahaha ok das stimmt haben wir nie weiter verfolgt
ich habe irgendwas geernt
und man muss jetzt aus irgendwelchen unerfindlichen gründen ewig warten bis die nächste runde losgeht
ne oder? ne muss man nicht
was ist denn der unterschied zwischen
ich mein es wäre sinnvoll
jetzt mal für
also für leute wie mich ne die keine ahnung von dem game haben es wäre vielleicht hier ganz gut
drei sätze was welche klasse ist
granate
ähm
wallhack oder sowas
und das ist
ne shotgun
das ist eben so ne defense klasse oder sowas
und das ist ne ok das ist der reken das ist der reken quasi
ok was kann man bei karts aus
ich finde das menü ziemlich
wie er
brauche ich dafür punkte das zu anlocken oder oder
wahrscheinlich brauche ich punkte dafür
also das menü fand ich jetzt bisschen unübersichtlich
wie gut geht der ad spam wichtig ad ad ad spam sieht ganz schön bescheuert aus
hui hüpfeln
kussgranate
moment hat man jetzt muss man gucken an mein auto hellstrike
ah mein wreck automatisch hellstrike
wie die dinger bekomme ich durch loot crates
den muss man doch frei spielen können kann man bestimmt frei spielen
keine 60 fps weiß nicht weil ich noch 720p eingestellt hatte
ich habe das gefühl es hat meine battlefield sensitivity settings
übernommen macht ganz guten eindruck
man kann hier nicht hoch doch kann man
und was mir auch nicht klar ist wo man hin muss
ok man muss da gut man muss wahrscheinlich dahin muss rot ist
warte warum ist hier
wie soll ich das einfach drauf schießen oder das kann es doch nicht sein
ok aktiv ok aktiv reload muss ich mich dran gewöhnen
der hat glitches real geht es hier schon los die die gegner sieht man verdammt schlecht
was hast du mittlerweile für ein set up guck dir mal das video von gestern an da bin ich
gerade dabei ein rechner zusammenzustellen
was von wo und warum
ok ne doch nicht aktiv reload
ja gestern
jonesen ich kauf mir einen 1000 8700k
also es sollte klar sein was ich dir zu sagen das ist geil das teil
ich hab sogar heute vorbestellt die sache ist die die meisten shops haben den also was
ist die meist und kein warum verlier ich leben
ah spawnschutz quasi ich blick null durch wo objectives sind und wo ich hin muss das
ist sehr verwirrend gemacht
ok ich glaube das ist halt das problem weil man sich wirklich null mit dem game vorher
beschäftigt hat
ich weiß absolut nicht wie ich das spielen muss
also ich würde jetzt vermuten ich muss zu dem plauen weil da steht pick up
und da steht auch pick up also gehen wir mal dahin
was mache ich damit
jetzt muss ich planten oder
ach das ist quasi demolition oder search and destroy oder sowas der spielen modus
alter was muss ich machen
game das kann so nicht sein dass das das nicht klar ist
muss ich jetzt eine bombe legen oder wie
wie ich das ich hab das ich hab das fof
der mächt mächt danke für den host also
hey leute wer zur mächt kommt ich hab keine ahnung von dem game nur mal so angemerkt
ne
ich hab mich nur mit dem game vorher beschäftigt du willst jetzt eigentlich plus mal kurze
stunde ausprobieren
aber ich muss sagen so dass
also dass das hätte das play so ist das ist nicht
irgendwie nicht sondern nicht klar was man machen muss
warum ist der rot obwohl obwohl es ein freund ist
wo ist der fof
eingestellt habe in die konflikt datei du gehst in in den dokumentor ordner bei dir
im winners explorer gehst in den dokumentor ordner da gibt es einen star wars battlefront
zwei multiplayer demo und da gibt es eine profile
pro profile unterstrich irgendwas ist 2 kilobyte kostet gestern gut sie gehste rein sucht ihr
viel durch wie du aus und probiert ein bisschen rum
wechselt man eigentlich ansicht
was ich ganz gut finde man hält nicht allzu viel aus das ist prinzipiell erstmal nicht
verkehrt
den außenwärts
da kommt noch mehr
stellst du uns mal hier lang
der hält ganz schön viel aus der tippe dahinten
was für monitor habe ich hab einen 144 hz bank monitor genau und genau ein typ kann ich dir
grad nicht sagen
wir bräuchten hier mehr mörsis ja das ist richtig tausend
ich ganz ehrlich ich steige null durch
ich steige absolut gar nicht durch
das hier ist quasi jetzt eine shotgun
was sagst du zu 240 hz monitorn
die frage ist erstmal ob es richtige 240 hz sind es gab ja da schon welche die quasi
120 waren und dafür die hintergrundbeleuchtung ausgeschaltet haben das finde ich nicht so
sinnvoll
aber ansonsten klar
mehr ist immer gut
vielleicht soll ich das fof ein bisschen runter stellen weil die gegner die sind so
dünn die siehst du kaum
und warum sind befreundete mit warum sind befreundete leute rot
und was bringt 204 hz dann bei gals die bettel von der bettel viel naja
wenn du den rechner hast ja ordentlich viel fps packt warum nicht ich meine man sieht
es hier guck mal ich meine ich habe hier 160 fps das ist das sind die ultra settings also
wenn ich das noch ein bisschen runter stellen würde komme ich da wahrscheinlich auf 200
plus
warum nicht vor allem wenn ich den wenn ich die neue cpu am start habe was meint ihr
wie es dann abgeht
warum hält der typ so viel aus
ad spam in jedem shooter wichtig essenziell auch ich habe keine granate mehr
gehen wir mal auf shotgun
ach jetzt kann man kann kann ich flanken kann man nicht flanken
ok ff scan da ist es quasi so ein hanso feil ja das ist ein hanso feil
ich steige null durch
kannst du fps ach seht ihr keine fps tru auf fack wie jetzt mal tru auf
render render tru auf konsole ich gehe mal weg konsole ich sehe nix render konsole ich
sehe nichts das ist scheiße tru auf screen info vielleicht
ja sind ja die fps überhaupt dabei
ne natürlich nicht
perf over ach ja stimmt wir sind ja auf einer neuen frost frostbite version perf over play
tru auf fps 1
perfekt so den anderen kack muss ich wieder ausschalten
so super funktioniert dokter gewalt hat mich geregt
richtig endlich setzt sich das mal durch dass man bloß 12 fps pro auge sieht
hanso hanso
was warum bin ich so schnell tot wie
warum machen die gegner so viel damage
siehens echt fühlt sich sehr balanced an
warum waren die gegner gefühlt 10 mal mehr damage ich werde weggecockt ja so siehts aus
aber ich meine ich hatte gefühlt mehr oder weniger die gleiche war von wie der irgendein
nahkampf ding ich schieß mit der shotgun drauf mach die
mix der schießt einmal auf mich drauf bin down
ich verstehe das nicht das gelbe ist glaube ich das ist auch zu hoch für mich
was sind das da eigentlich
hallo granate, granate gibt es nicht
meinte ich brauche meine gunner optics dann geht das besser
ich finde das game bis jetzt irgendwie einfach mir
also gut das ist auch mehr oder weniger die erste richtige runde ich finde es
wir
was battle points sind es sowas wie killstreaks oder was
aber den gegner am start nee
okay ich muss mich echt dran gewöhnen dass das meine eigenen leute rot markiert werden
das verwirrt mich richtig
die optik ist nice, da hast du recht also gut aussehen tut das
das sieht richtig gut aus und es läuft doppelt so gut wie cod
da fliegt was
gibt's gibt's flank flank kann man flanken wenigstens
das stimmt okay ist f ist ist der hanso fall ich habe null durchgepflegt
es also wie gesagt ich habe mich ja null über das game informiert ich spiele jetzt erst
mal es fühlt sich es fühlt sich verwirrend wir irgendwie an
du weißt überhaupt nicht was das game von dir möchte gerade
man denkt man kann rechts flanken aber dann ist eine wand
der gegner war schon das ein und man kann zehn mal drauf schießen
das war das war wahrscheinlich in den held oder so als gegner
ja gibt gibt first person
spiel strike das ist wie rush okay dann spielen wir mal strike
gleich wieder 2k fps strike spiel mal rush rush ist gut da weiß ich
wenigstens wie der spielmodus funktioniert und wir haben anscheinend
irgendwelche points kann man jetzt mit den points was anlocken
ladebildschirm natürlich net okay equipped cards
ich meine warum schreiben die nicht wenigstens hier mal hin wie man das freischaltet
so nach dem motto kostet eins von irgendwas oder so
für mich ist es nicht verständlich als jemand dass ich mit dem game null beschäftigt hat
wie ich mir so ein ding hier freischalte keine ahnung
aber gut aussehen tut es das muss man sagen das sieht wirklich sehr hübsch aus
was die gibts in loot crates und loot crates krieg ich für gespielte runden oder wie krieg
ich loot crates ach die cards sind erst mal im lounge verfügbar
steht das da irgendwo
flankerino geht natürlich nicht fragt man sich jetzt natürlich warum gibts den teil
der map
stand unten links sehr gut da hab ich da hingekommen flankerino flankenpeste
holen wir holen jetzt mal die shotgun raus was war aber wie bettelpacks
recht shotgun die werden jetzt geohnt
oder auch nicht
das ist ne ne das ist nicht der standard fof das ist das ist ich glaub 90 oder 95
da gehts lang es ist auch geil dass mich das game so spawn da gehts um was
wird die effe ich bin hier gespawnt warum werde ich beschossen
ich brauch ein shotgun shotgun
und wo gehts hier unten lang
also ich sag es euch ganz ehrlich das game macht null spaß
also zumindest mir nicht das fühlt sich komisch an fühlt sich einfach nur komisch an was
warum ist hinter uns what the fuck wir spawnen da doch
der fluss ist so der fluss von dem game ist irgendwie merkwürdig also
dann hast du wahnsinns op gegner manchmal
ja
Warum hat er jetzt so viel ausgehalten?
What the fuck?
Die Klasse wechseln, weil die sackt oder wie?
Die Klasse sackt, aha.
Und was sackt weniger?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Es gibt Games, die findet man irgendwie, man kann es nicht beschreiben, so aus dem
Bauch aus, so instinktiv, schon nach der ersten Runde, doof und ich fürchte, das Game gehört
für mich persönlich dazu.
Ja, es gibt bestimmt noch viel, was man ausprobieren kann, obwohl ich überhaupt keine Ahnung von
dem Game habe, aber fuck, aber es macht mir null Spaß, null.
Es ist, es ist auch sinnlos, es ist Spawnen drauf, Spawnen drauf, klar, das wird nicht
so sein, wenn man es koordiniert spielt.
Das einzige, was mir bis jetzt gefällt, es sieht gut aus und mein Problem ist, wenn ich
schon so im Game starte, habe ich auch keine Lust, mich weiter damit zu beschäftigen,
vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr was rauszukriegen.
Kann man Battlefront 2 mit Battlefield 1 vergleichen, nö, das ist sowas zum aufstellen,
ja, one is a Gatling gun, F ist, F ist ein Schild, ok, das ist cool, ok, wir sind geschockt,
ok, ne, das sind also 48 FPS Stream ich gerade, wir schneiden jetzt, wir schneiden jetzt
mal, mal ausprobieren und hier stand, es kommt erst bei Release, oder wie?
Ah, Available at Launch, aha, Schneiber Action, Quickscope, Radar, Thermo, Dings, Fisch,
Thermo, Dings, brauchen wir nicht, jetzt ist meine Sensitivity zu hoch, ah, die Sensitivity
ist zu hoch, was ist Q noch mal gewesen, ah, Granate, Active Freeload, aha, da oben ist
einer, No Scope, oh, ich muss die Sens runterstellen, fuck, alter, trifft ja nix, trifft ja nix,
ich muss die Sens runterstellen, das geht nicht, das funktioniert nicht, ich darf die
Maus einen Zentimeter bewegen und bin halb immer wildstärkt drüber, lol, das klappt
nicht, das ist irgendwie 20 GB, das ist das, ja ach, ich weiß, dass meine Sens zu niedrig
ist, äh, zu hoch ist, ich kann das gar nicht umstellen, alter, meine Sens, ich krieg Anfälle,
okay, umstellen, schnell, schnell, schnell, umstellen, äh, äh, so, mal gucken, ob es
jetzt besser geht, nein, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu wenig, Zoom-Sens, 30, na okay,
das, vielleicht, vielleicht einfach noch ein Ticken höher, na ja, das ist immer noch
ein bisschen wenig, das ist ein bisschen wenig, wat, wat, wat, wat, wat, wat, wat, wat, wat,
wat?
What?
Hä?
Warum, warum ownt mich das auf range so, wat ist das für ein Ding?
ist das das heavy ist die op klasse
schrägt
ja man sagt ja auch nicht mehr in 2k17 man sagt einfach in current hier
ich streame mit 48 fps weil ich finde das reicht
sieht flüssig genug aus und man hat bloß 6 m mit bitrate
dann sieht es vielleicht ein bisschen besser aus wenn es weniger fps sind
so eine runde spiele ich auf jeden fall noch
aber das spiel macht mir null, null spaß
ich habe da ein häkchen dran
weil ich ihn ausgewählt habe
jetzt kannst du auch das kannst du so passen und fast passen spiel
aber ich also wenn es auch nur ansatzweise wie im ersten teil ist dann
macht first person eigentlich keinen sinn
aha gut dass man jetzt hier einfach mal ewig rumsitzen muss bis es losgeht
na mister fies also optisch sieht das saumäßig gut aus das game
optisch sieht das also das ist das einzige was mir gefällt bis jetzt
aber ich weiß nicht ob ihr das ob ihr das auch manchmal habt wenn ihr
den spiel das erste mal anmacht ihr habt keine ahnung von dem game
und so bauchgefühl ist schon nach nach den ersten drei vier minuten dass es
ein quasi überwindung kostet weiter zu spielen
dann ist ja das game ist nix für euch ich will noch nicht mal sagen dass es
schlecht ist für jeden oder so aber es ist nix für mich wichtig wie wie viel
zu 60 kann man machen
das ist nämlich ganz ganz wichtiges kriterium man konnte irgendwo auf die
mauern rauf das muss ich mir mal angucken wie das funktioniert
ich checke nicht warum auf einmal ein gegner hinter mir lang kommt und das ist
viel zu langsam hier es gibt keine sniper sense gibt keine sniper sense es
gibt bloß eine ironside sense was misst es ist viel zu langsam hier jetzt
das muss man die fände gut als wir die fänden
aber ja wir fänden das ja moment das muss wir die fände das müssen wir
attacken machen wir das doch moment ist das was wir attacken soll den gegner
verstehe wir sollen den wohl am fliehen hindern
ach ok und wenn man dann ist das wenn man dann genug punkte hat kann man
irgendwie den held freischalten oder so
was machen außer mich mal hier hinter dem felsen zu
verstecken weil die garantiert jemand hinrennt gleich
spielst auf ultra settings ja alles ultra also man muss sagen optik und
performance grandios vor allem wenn man davor die beta von world war two
denkst oder flutig gespielt hat
ja so kann man ungefähr beschreiben es kommt mir vom gameplay einfach wir vor
irgendwie max was hältst du von pupke ich ich verstehe den bettel royal halb
nicht pupke ist spannend also die runden sind schon spannend aber es ist
jetzt auch nichts was mich wochen monatelang an dem game hält aber der
aber der bettel royal halb erschließt sich mir nicht
es ist spannend ja aber was nicht das pupke hat mich auch nicht so geschockt
fortnight ist viel geiler weiß nicht fortnight hat bei mir schon durch ihr
pay to win zeug verloren gehabt als also ich hatte es mir ganz kurz überlegt
runterzuladen als das neu war als das das war damals noch so ein quasi so ein
also wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung habe noch so ein zombie modus game oder
so am anfang so mit verbarrikadieren und so was hat schon ein bisschen was
durchgelesen und wollte ausprobieren und dann habe ich gesehen dass das quasi
ein early access free to ein ein möchte gern free to play early access was aber
was kostet und pay to win ist game ist und habe ich mir nach lernen spiele ich
kein fortnight ja bedeutet free to play denn auch dass es dort also wie fair ist
das free to play in fortnight falls es jemand gespielt hat weil wenn es dann
da auch wieder irgendwelche op sachen aus boxen gibt und so was zum beispiel
dann ist es dann ist es scheiße
man kann nichts kaufen das wundert mich jetzt weil das originale fortnight war
ja ziemlich man hat gemerkt dass es ein free to play pay to win werden soll
alter alter wollte mich verarschen leute
rektisch ok was würdest du sagen gefällt dem spiel auch also gewisse
struktur oder struktur die man begreift feint tuning weiß nicht es es wirkt so
zusammengewürfelt irgendwie ich kann es nicht beschreiben aber das ist ein game
wo ich jetzt schon die erste runde einfach das gefühl habe das macht mir
kein bock guckt euch mal warum habe ich den feind gewonnen
ich habe den ich habe diesen feind nicht zu gewinnen
der tue man nicht von hinten gerecht und ich habe schild angemacht mich
umgedrehten weg geblastert warum
achtung den außenwärts
deswegen soll passen dass man was sieht
aber warum das game ist komisch
der fluss ist nicht eingängig da ist irgendwie komisch
es fällt mir wirklich verdammt schwer zu zu beschreiben wie sich das game für
mich anfühlt es fühlt sich komisch anders es fühlt sich so
anders hat man keine lust es zu spielen oder dass ich jetzt genau beschreiben
könnte ohne mir längere zeit gedeihten zu machen warum
bähm
ich würde sagen get schreckt schnell aufheben aufheben aufheben ich habe
dem grad mal eine komplette ladung den kopf geschossen hatte nicht gejuckt
mit der minigun auf die da war ich jetzt mal ich kann jetzt kann jetzt hier mit
irgendwie so was spawnen ein rock rocket trooper flametrooper kipps war mal mit dem
genau kenny so geht es mir auch du checkst überhaupt nicht was abgeht so
unstrukturiert okay flammenwerfer okay das ist eine
granate achtung
okay gut dann ist
von oben ok als nächstes bornen wir mal mit dem warum habe ich überhaupt punkte
gekriegt für nichts oder was für kacke sein habe ich punkte gekriegt max was hältst du
von rainbow siege am anfang nicht gut mittlerweile gutes game leider leider
schwierig einzukommen jetzt also da habe ich zumindest in eindruck
der heavy tüp scheint mir ein bisschen op zu sein
der scheint mir ein bisschen op zu sein der typ
top walk ich bin generell für maps und und spielmodi mit einer gewissen mit einer gewissen
struktur also so die wo in sich klar ist was zu tun ist wo man merkt wo man wo man predikten
kann was gegner machen also es mag sein dass das hier auch alles so ist ja ich bin offensichtlich
ziemlich scheiße in dem game aber das gefühl habe ich gerade mal kurz regnen spielst du
den offer war hier ab und zu mal zumindest also ich habe da ich habe in offer war über
tausend stunden allerdings mit letzter zeit wenig
man kann ja gar nicht flenken habe ich vergessen doch man kann hier rein das ist nice hintertür
von wo ich habe den gegner nicht gesehen am anfang ich kann jetzt ich kann jetzt wieder
sparen als als rocket schuppers sparen wir jetzt mal
also frage mal was für e-sports für bei welchen games sich die e-sport szene verfolge
overwatch fast alles okay was hat man hier chat pack nice chat pack rakete was ist das
seitliches chat pack auch das ist das nice mach die tür auf
direkt voll die rakete in die fresse warum hat der typ eigentlich eine komplette rakete
ins gesicht ausgehalten was kugeln sonst noch so starcraft
manchmal cs hab ich früher fast alles geguckt mittlerweile weniger
was ich nicht mag heroes of the storm guck ich auch nicht alles aber auch größere events
was ich komischerweise nicht mag ist lol und dota
was aber die halbe map
direkt der irgendwie habe ich den eindruck die heavy klasse ist ziemlich op
so bisschen oder so bisschen op ja tatsächlich gucke ich auch ab und zu mal heart stone weil
gerade eine heart stone geschrieben hat ab und zu gucke ich tatsächlich auch mal heart
stone
das spiel sieht 1 zu 1 so aus wie teil 1 teil 1 sah auch schon geil aus was was was
ich bei teil 1 nicht gesehen habe sind hier so so platter physik effekte und so haben wir
ein follow-up danke danke ich glaube aber nicht also falls du folgst wegen battlefront
ich glaube nicht dass ich das game noch oft spielen werden
die battlefront 1 beta das war ja dieser rush modus und dieser objective modus da hat man
finde ich relativ klar strukturiert verstanden was passiert und wo was herkommt das geht mir
hier gerade ein bisschen ab ja patrick bis dann würde ich sagen für die ganzen follows
den haben wir hier alles am start den black fire lp den hutbär den ti 2811 h simon volkart
feit ologos der aneuig alex edwin der king itsmith und mehr sehe ich nicht mehr so kann
man jetzt hier neue sachen ausrüsten kraft das ist auch so was wo sehe ich denn wie viel
wie viel material ich schon habe das menü ist ist sehr verwirrend kann man freunde einladen
vermute mal wobei sicher ist hier nix wo sehe ich denn wie viel ich zum kraft brauche
wir flanken jetzt wir flanken hierdurch easy flank easy flank einfach mal ein acht gegner
reingeflenkt hallo bester flank aller Zeiten
übrigens ich glaube die gegner haben team falls man mit freunden spielen kann die machen
das ziemlich koordiniert und laufen zusammen und sowas
ja ich bin ziemlich oft am streben in letzter zeit das stimmt schon hast du schon öfters
dungeon fragens gespielt einmal einmal ich spiele einen zwergen wäre wenn das interessiert
ein zweier klär der hintergrundgeschichte ist dann nicht so viel zu holen ehrlich gesagt
ich spiele gerne support in RPGs flank flanken flank action weil ich mich frage wo die wo
die gegner sind da ich bin voll dran vorbei gerannt
echt haben wir sie auf man ich stecke fest ich konnte mich nicht mehr bewegen ich war
gestackt im baum
die musik wiederholt sich auch schnell
ich spiele jetzt mal wieder assault so jetzt nachdem ich halbwegs gecheckt habe was die
einzelnen fähigkeiten machen jetzt müssen wir hierhin die fan ach ok ich glaube so
langsamer sicher habe ich verstanden wie das ganze funktioniert was ich ein bisschen
fragwürdig finde ist dass dann dass dann quasi gegner immer im rücken sind weil man pendelt
das ist merkwürdig man pendelt ja zwischen den zwei punkten hin und her das ist quasi
capture the flack wenn man so will das ist quasi capture the flack und aber problem ist
halt wenn die gegner attacken dahin und man spawn dann hinter denen dann stehen sie einem
im rücken und wir denen im rücken und so das das ist merkwürdig das ist komisch das ist
ganz komisch muss sein bäme in your face damit hat es nicht gerechnet auch hanso hanso
feil
hanso mein beide wei
auch hinter mir sind granaten ich muss weg
einfach die geometrie
oh was das oh wir haben verloren
fed company 3 zu schön wärs
schön wärs
warum ich hier wupplos heiß weil ich den account erstellt habe ohne dass ich irgendwie
gedacht habe da schon anfangen werde zu streben
warum kann man in in diesem zwischen bildschirm keine waffen und laut aus editieren
ah jetzt geht das
wie viel punkte habe ich denn zum kraft wo steht das denn
wo steht hier oben oder was ist das da das gleiche wobei das symbol anders ist ich bin
ich nicht um das finde das ganz lustig so ich gehe mal davon aus dass hier ist das
hier sonst ergibt es nämlich keinen sinn weil dieses symbol finde ich sonst nirgendwo
wieder jetzt ist 99 98 was ist das da oben game was möchtest du mir sagen
was du willst von mir
warum haben wir das package schon die runde gegen was los
jetzt weiß man nicht ob noch mehr hinter einem sind oder nicht
weg
machen wir wir geben im cover
hallo
habe ich das jetzt
noch mehr recht
double recht
rectangle
sehe ich dass die spawns quasi sind das 2 cp spawns sehe ich das richtig
quasi 2 cp spawns
ich mach das jetzt pick up ich will pick up darf ich nicht
das sind richtige 2 cp spawns die gegner spawnen hinter dem ziel wer hält sowas eigentlich
für eine gute idee
guck jetzt sind die gegner wieder hinter uns und wir müssen nach da das ist ganz ganz
merkwürdig das system also schon fast ein bisschen fragwürdig irgendwo na guck es euch
an jetzt sind nämlich die gegner hinter mir das ist echt frag das ist wirklich sehr fragwürdig
wie das aufgebaut ist
jetzt dann musst du umdrehen zum objekte von die gegner sind die quasi im rücken und
spawnen allerdings spawnen wiederum vor dir das heißt du bist immer sandwich das ist
sehr fragwürdig
wer sich das ausgedacht hat und das für eine gute idee hielt ich weiß nicht
außerdem fehlen gute sounds es fehlen ganz wichtig gute sounds so nach dem motto äh
ich sag nur keine ahnung flag captured flag dropped ich mein es ist ja sowas wie in der
richtung gecaptured flag wisst ihr was ich meine dass man quasi ohne direkt hin zu gucken
sieht was sache ist ich hab gar nicht mitgekriegt dass wir jetzt das ding schon wieder haben
mittlerweile
ja sehr merkwürdig sehr sehr merkwürdig so jetzt wir schneiden noch mal ne runde sniper
2k17
also der 16 gegen 16 modus ist irgendwie komisch gucken wir uns noch mal kurz den
anderen an vielleicht habe ich den anderen modus ja
unrecht getan zwar die erste runde
das ist so fehl dass die gegner das gesporn bleiben und wir wieder hier zum zum abholen
müssen was ist warum
guck sandwich gegner spawnen hinter ein und waren noch von vorher vor einem
das wird so dumm das wäre echt zu dumm was hältst du von i9 und amd cpus amd hat wieder
richtig gut aufgeholt i9 bisschen
bisschen overkill
auch der takt ist jetzt nicht so der wahnsinn für halt games dann lieber neun dann lieber
den neuen i7
so wir spielen wir spielen jetzt noch mal hier den den ja galactic assault spielen wir noch
mal
ich speichere mir die runde mal falls ich auf die blöde idee kommt dazu ein video aufzunehmen
aber ich glaube nicht
das ist eines der wir obwohl es obwohl es eigentlich ein ziemlich akade casual mäßiges
game sein sollte ist eines der der der wirsten spiel
irgendwie gefühlt was ich seit langem hatte bei einem eigentlich vermutet relativ simplen
baller game
ich hole mir wieder ein intel ja ich hole mir den 8700k richtig
liegt das vielleicht an meinem fof ist das zu hoch ist das game nicht darauf ausgelegt
das mal ne 90er fof hat man weiß ja nie kann er sagen
ich weiß ich weiß nicht was mich trifft ehrlich gesagt
ok wir gehen alle links durch weil es cool ist links durchzugehen
der 8700k ist krass krasser shit
es gibt wieder so maßlos op helden wie im ersten teil
da habe ich keinen bock drauf so was muss doch nicht sein muss das sein zumal man ja
auch wenn man das hier richtig sieht das sind ja auch keine kill streaks in dem sind das
sind so das sind quasi score streaks mit einem mit einem perk dass man sie nicht beim beim
beim sterben verliert was heißt jeder depp kann sich hier irgendwann mal so ein held
spielen gefällt mir nicht ich finde helden braucht es nicht
also generell finde ich soll sowas immer blöd vor allem wenn es nicht daran gebunden
ist ob man gut oder schlecht spielt klar wenn man gut spielt oder oder sag mal so wenn man
wenn man gut und kriegt man so schneller aber ich habe schon gameplays gesehen irgendwie
35 5 mit irgendeinem held und sowas das muss nicht sein das muss wirklich nicht sein
und das ist der erste typ am start und die mechanics von den helden sahen auch ziemlich
langweilig aus was ich gesehen habe heute mittag in dem video
ich meine guckt euch das mal an guckt warum braucht es sowas warum muss das sein
ja helden gegen helden ist cool da nehme ich dir recht da also zumindest stelle ich mir
vor dass das gut funktioniert aber so ich war in der fahrt warum das ist quasi wie
ein wie ein wie ein wie ein dauer AC 130 oder sowas
was das ist was ist der sinn von von battlefront mit einem helden schnetzeln oder was beziehungsweise
was heißt schnetzeln mit dem held absolut unterlegene bobs bashen
weiß nicht was daran der sinn sein soll
ach das ist offline held gegen held ok guckt euch das mal an hier liegt nicht daran oder
so weil weil hält oder nein kann nicht sein
also quasi wer zuerst hält gewinnt oder wie ist das ganze ich weiß nicht das game fühlt
sich irgendwie irgendwie und durchdacht und ich wie gesagt mir fällt schwer zu beschreiben
aber ich glaube ich hör jetzt auf zu spielen es macht mir null spaß
muss man dann als team agieren und gemeinsam versuchen zu killen was allerdings bedeutet
wenn man das macht das quasi als dann damit unterstellt man ja den gegnern dass das restliche
team der gegner nichts tut wenn man quasi sein eigenes team braucht um einen gegner
zu können wieviel bettel viel ist in dem game ich merke wenig von bettel viel die grafik
erinnert an bettel field kennst du black desert hast du es gespielt klar haben sogar gestrebt
und spiel als spieler ab und zu mal noch ich habe ein 60er oder fast 60er wizard ne also
nils und mir macht es keinen spaß absolut nicht wo kommen denn jetzt gegner von da
der ist lauter typ den mussten wir jetzt schälen und beschen nein können wir nicht
weil hier die map vorbei ist auch gut
ich will noch mal schneidern
das ist teken zu langsam wichtig wichtig leute wichtig ich muss was ausprobieren
und man sniped aus der hüfte genau auf diesen einen punkt
aber ich will ich will aber nur einmal wenigstens schneidern
moment warum ist da was
wo ist denn hier was
mein was ist das geh weg geh weg
hallo gegner
du siehst hier noch no scope an andere droide
es ist ja auch nicht so wirklich das ist glaube ich auch nicht so wirklich ein slimeball das
ist eher so ein halbautomat so ja ach nee man kann so schnell schießen bis überladen
ach so also ich kann quasi so machen ja das ist nice da kann ordentlich drauf fahren
ok gut ok ich brauche ich brauche ein richtigen ich brauche ein richtig geilen sniper
ha
was einmal das jetzt macht?
Suche Gegner und Sucheteam!
Geht da näher was?
Was?!
Wo?
Powerful enemy.
MTT, Target weapons.
Grenade armed.
Wat?
Super, ich hab mich jetzt selbst geschockt.
Kann man sich, kann man sich hinknien?
Ah, sei gut.
MTT hit. Multiple units destroyed.
Ah, das sind Tickets, die man wieder aufgefüllt kriegt.
Okay, das ist ein ganz gutes System.
Ja, die Heavy-Klasse ist OP, das, äh, den Eindruck hatte ich auch.
Was will das Teil denn, äh?
Ich glaub, da jetzt als Sniper reinzugehen, das ist nicht so clever.
Woa!
Ich blicke da mal durch, was ist denn hier los?
Was ist das, Assault-Rifle, oder wie?
Komisch, ganz komisch.
Wir spielen jetzt mal OP-Klasse wieder.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen, wenn das Ding noch einen Granatwerfer hat.
Ich mein, ich hab ja vorhin schon einfach von der Seite sieben Leute weggerotzt.
Äh, Game?
Wozu gibt es den Teil der Map?
Ich hab Schiss.
Oh nee, äh.
Am wenigsten ist er noch verreckt an der Granate.
Kann man hier drüber?
Oh oh, oh oh, oh oh.
Ganz, ganz schlechte Idee.
Dafuck!
So viele Spiele diesen Monat zu wenig Zeit.
Also ich hab mich dazu entschlossen, ich kauf mir kein neues Cod.
Und ich kauf mir auch kein Battlefront.
Was kommt sonst noch den Monat raus?
Ähm.
Gibt's sonst noch was Schönes?
Rennspiele, also Rennspiele kommen raus, aber Rennspiele jucken mich auch nicht.
Ah, das neue Gosset kommt raus, stimmt.
Ja, das guck ich mir an.
Das guck ich mir auf jeden Fall an.
FIFA bestimmt nicht.
Ist das die Screed? Naja.
Mal gucken.
Die Dinger kann man doch noch nicht switchen, so wie es für mich aussieht.
Warum ist hier hinten um mich alles rot?
Äh, wat? Wat?
But why?
Nein, warum?
Wie ist deine Meinung zu Star Wars Battlefront 2?
Mir macht's null Spaß.
Ich spiele es ja so nochmal, dass ich das wenigstens auch ein bisschen besser einschätzen kann, warum es mir keinen Spaß macht.
Aber es macht mir null Spaß.
Es sieht geil aus, die Performance ist geil.
Aber es macht mir keinen Spaß.
Watch this.
Ich watch it.
Optik und Performance können sie ja. Sound können sie auch.
Keine Frage.
Aber ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, dass sie seit Company 2 und Battlefield 3 Gameplay ein bisschen verlernt haben.
Richtig geil, dass es überhaupt Helden gibt, finde ich auch sinnlos.
Ich finde es einfach sinnlos, wenn es so Ultra-OP-Dinger gibt.
Ich meine, der Typ, der konnte es schlicht und ergreifend, den hält wahrscheinlich einfach nicht spielen.
Aber man hat schon gesehen, wie viel er aushält im Vergleich zu so einem random Typ, der hier rumrennt.
Und man denkt, man könnte hier rüber flanken, aber gibt es nichts.
Killstreaks sind auch sinnlos, ja.
Aber wenigstens resetten die, dann man stirbt.
Was?
Was ist das?
Warum geht die Tür nicht mehr auf?
Ich meine, was ist das?
Wo komme ich jetzt mal an?
Ja, alles klar, alles super, plus dass mir das Game keinen Spaß macht.
Regen, reg dich, Alter.
Ich will da keine Helden spielen, deswegen finde ich das Game wahrscheinlich auch kacke.
Ich will überhaupt keine Helden spielen.
Ich will irgendwas Balance zu spielen, was die Gegner auch spielen.
Regen.
Aussehen tut das Spiel, ja.
Ich würde sagen, die Helden sind eher so etwas wie ein Killstreak, der nicht resetet.
Komisches Game.
Ganz, ganz komisches Game.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt schon keinen Bock mehr auf das Game.
Wie soll das dann erstmal werden, wenn man das ein paar Monate gespielt hat?
Die resetten gar nicht.
Also ich bin so oft gestorben und hatte danach noch Battle Points.
Oh, Crates gibt es.
Crates, jawoll.
Wir öffnen jetzt mal Crates.
Ja, Skeeter, das Problem ist, dass es sowas gibt.
Also, wie gesagt, ich sage nicht, dass es einem keinen Spaß machen darf.
Ich sage nur, dass es mir nicht gefällt.
It's a sniper.
Ah, okay.
Victory Pose, wer braucht sowas?
Quip.
Ah, okay.
Guck mal, was da sonst noch so drinnen ist.
Nein, hat sie nicht.
Oft gemacht.
Ja, Büffel finde ich auch.
Überall muss es irgendwelche Unlocks, also gegen Unlocks habe ich ja nichts,
aber so random luckbasiertes Zeug geben.
Wozu?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das habe ich schon.
Machen wir noch mal ein Game mit dem neuen Zeug.
Kann man sie wenigstens auch mit echtem Geld kaufen?
Weiß ich nicht, aber so wie ich die einschätze, bestimmt.
Der Menü ist auch sehr hakelig.
Ach, ich dachte, ich komme jetzt zu Paypal.
Bitte Paypal.
Hier kann man später bestimmt Echtgeld-Zeugs reinstecken.
Aktuell habe ich 915 Dollar quasi, 20 Crafting-Teile und null von diesem Ding auch immer.
Ich weiß nicht, warum es drei verschiedene Währungen braucht.
Wahrscheinlich, damit man den Zusammenhang zwischen Ingame-Dollar und Echtgeld-Euro nicht so leicht herstellt.
Also, wie gehabt.
Power Up with Star Cards.
Einer ist ein Tutorial.
Jetzt haben wir Equipped.
Ich weiß, dass wir das Equipped haben.
Wir spielen jetzt noch eine Runde.
Was ich an FIFA nicht verstehe, ist, warum das die Leute mitmachen.
Weil, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ich habe nie Geld ausgegeben in FIFA.
Ich habe auch die letzten FIFA-Teile nicht gekauft.
Aber, wenn ich das richtig sehe, wenn man dann quasi von FIFA 2016 auf 2018 upgradet,
dann verfällt quasi alles, was man sich für FIFA 2016 gekauft hat in diesem Ingame-Markt.
Oder sehe ich das falsch?
Und wenn ja, warum machen die Leute das?
Es gibt ja sogar Leute, die kaufen sich wohl das Game früher, dass sie früher in den Shop kommen.
Also, sie pre-ordern das und kaufen sich das bei irgendwelchen Shops, wo es das früher gibt,
nur, dass sie früher in den Shop kommen.
Warum machen das die Leute mit?
Das verstehe ich. Ich kann ja vieles nachvollziehen irgendwie.
Aber bei FIFA, warum man da mitmacht, verstehe ich nicht.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Moment, die Digger kann man steuern.
Krass.
Also, bei FIFA verstehe ich nicht, wie man da mitmachten kann.
Bei Overwatch zum Beispiel. Bei Overwatch verstehe ich, warum man sich Loot Crates kauft.
Also, ich, beziehungsweise ich kann sagen, warum ich mir Loot Crates in Overwatch gekauft habe.
Erstens, weil Blizzard mit die beste Design- und Art-Abteilung hat von allem.
Weil ich in das Spiel so viele hunderte Stunden reingesteckt habe
und die Entwickler quasi zusätzlich unterstützen wollte.
Deswegen habe ich mir Loot Crates gekauft in Overwatch.
Natürlich kam da auch ein bisschen der psychologische Anreize nach dem Motto,
ja, die Summer-Game-Packs gibt es quasi nur einmal im Jahr und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber in Overwatch ist das ja wirklich komplett optional.
Und in vielen Turnieren sind Skills ja sogar gebannt.
In vielen Turnieren sind Skills ja sogar gebannt, dass man es besser erkennt.
Regen, bitte! Regen, bitte!
Rekt.
Noch mehr Rekt. Ultra-Rekt.
Von hinten kommt was.
Guckt mal, was der aushält. Guckt euch das mal an. Seht ihr das?
Das ist halt null fair, sowas. Null.
Doch, FIFA 2004. Ja, FIFA 2004 habe ich auch mal irgendwann gespielt.
Ja, Black Fire, es hat ja auch prinzipiell keiner gegen, wenn jemand entscheidet, sein Geld für In-Game-Sachen auszugeben.
Aber man muss ja immer mal ein bisschen abwägen.
Und wie gesagt, Overwatch-Lootcredits habe ich mir auch gekauft.
Ich habe mir auch des einen oder anderen Heroes of the Storm-Skin gekauft.
Oder in Black Desert habe ich mir auch ein paar Value-Packs gekauft.
Ich sage ja da gar nichts dagegen. Es kann ja jeder mit seinem Geld letztendlich machen, was er will.
Ich finde aber das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis und das Fairness-Verhältnis bei FIFA schlecht.
Deswegen verstehe ich es nicht, aus meiner Sicht gesprochen, warum das Leute machen.
Ich verstehe das nicht. Ich würde mir niemals für FIFA-Günschgelten Geld ausgeben.
Vor allem nicht mit dem Hinblick darauf, dass das nächste Jahr alles wieder weg ist.
Wenn ich LoL oder Dota spielen würde, würde ich wahrscheinlich auch Skins kaufen.
Aber ich finde, das ist alles noch mal nicht ganz so eine harte Nummer wie in FIFA.
Und ich finde, dass sowas sollte, dass ich es überhaupt unterstütze.
Es sollte entweder ein Free-2-Play-Game sein, was in Stile Press of Exile, wo ich quasi alles spielen kann, nur Komfortfunktionen kaufen kann.
Allerdings, wenn es Free-2-Play ist, dann sage ich, ich will euch jetzt wirklich unterstützen.
Das Game macht Spaß. Ich habe da hunderte Stunden reingesteckt.
Oder aber, wenn es eben ein Game ist, was man sich Vollpreis kauft, und das ist ja FIFA,
dann sollten es reine Kosmetik-Sachen sein, wie in Overwatch.
Es kann nicht sein, dass man jedes Jahr einen neuen Vollpreis-Teil kauft,
und man gibt Geld aus, damit das, was man sich fürs alte gekauft hat, quasi verfällt.
Weil, ich meine, wenn man sich 2017 kauft und 2017 spielt, und das quasi dadurch durch den Kauf schon mal unterstützt, hat man alles in den Sand gesetzt für letztes Jahr.
Ja, Hearthstone ist okay, verstehe ich. Hearthstone habe ich mir auch ein paar Decks gekauft.
Man kann sich jetzt darüber streiten, ob es zu teuer ist.
Man muss mit allen Metadecks spielen. Keine Ahnung. Aber Hearthstone kostet wenigstens nichts.
Hearthstone ist kein Spiel in dem Sinn, wie bei FIFA.
Für mich hat ein Vollpreis-Spiel einfach so den Anspiel, also zumindest den Anspiel, den ich an Vollpreis-Spielen habe, ist,
ich nehme mir ein Game an, da steht ein Preis dran, und wenn ich diesen Preis bezahle, kann ich es in vollem Umfang spielen und den Content nutzen.
Und deswegen finde ich es auch sehr skeptisch, deswegen finde ich es auch nicht gut, dass es zum Beispiel bei Battlefield,
das Ding fliegt aber nicht, sondern ich weiß, dass es bei Battlefield Waffenpacks gibt, also Unlockpacks.
Wenn die Spieldesigner sich gedacht haben, man soll 50 Stunden grinden, um in diesem Vollpreis-Spiel quasi in den Genuss zu kommen, das und das spielen zu können,
dann soll gefälligt jeder die gleichen Mittel und die gleichen Voraussetzungen in dem Game haben und 50 Stunden grinden.
Das ist ein Vollpreis-Spiel. Ich will den Inhalt so benutzen, wie sich die Designer gedacht haben, ohne Abkürzung, ohne Shortcuts oder sonst was.
Aber das ist leider nicht mehr so.
Oh, ich bin gleich down, ich muss weg.
Ich muss weg.
Ich habe fast gekillt, wie auch immer habe ich, wie auch immer ich das jetzt gemacht habe, als wären sie gereckt.
Ich spam einfach mal raus, dann wird schon was kommen, klar.
Ist der Hanzo feil.
Wo geht hier was?
Ich checke nicht, wo hier was herkommt.
Da bin ich aber weggekommen. Ich hätte das Schild wegmachen können, wegspringen.
Sehe ich genauso Premium-Geschichten bei Battlefield und die ganzen Shortcut-Kits, die es gibt.
Wenn man sich überlegt, was das Game in, sagen wir mal, in so einer, was weiß ich, Digital, Blah, irgendwas, Edition oder so,
was einem immer nahelegen zu kaufen, wenn man sich sowas kauft, quasi 70 Euro schon bei Release ausgeben.
Und dann noch ein Season Pass, den es ja wohl jetzt nicht mehr gibt oder so, habe ich gelesen, keine Ahnung.
Mal gucken.
Wie gesagt, ich kann das noch aus meiner Sicht sagen, ich verstehe nicht, warum das Leute bei FIFA mitmachen.
Ah, kommt wieder. Die Fairness in Person als Held.
Na ja, dann kann ich wieder ein Game von meiner Liste streichen, was ich mir kaufen werde.
Wie gesagt, soll nicht heißen, dass dieses Game hier niemandem Spaß machen darf.
Das verstehen ja Leute immer ganz gerne falsch, aber mein Fall ist es wirklich nicht.
Wie ist denn der Quickscope-Faktor von diesem Spiel, mir macht es keinen Spaß.
Gar nicht, seit der ersten Runde nicht.
Also ich habe, seit wann stream ich? Uptime, Moment, ich gucke mal Uptime.
Zwei Stunden, ich hatte seit zwei Stunden keinen Spaß an diesem Spiel.
Null, gar nicht.
Noch, noch ohne Microtransactions.
Was gibt es denn hier sonst noch? Career.
Ok, das Menü ist auch sehr, sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Was? Zwei Level noch, dann habe ich das Cap erreicht, ok.
Kriegt man dann irgendwas?
Was ist das für ein hässliches Teil?
Boba Fett Schiff, ok.
Ja, ok, also wenn man, wenn das stimmt, dass man quasi in,
in 1.5 Level Max Rank erreicht hat.
Wollen wir es bis zum Ende durchziehen?
Wie gesagt, 18 Uhr habe ich mal ein Dungeon & Dragons Game.
Da bin ich eh spätestens weg.
Wollen wir es durchziehen? Wollen wir bis Max Level spielen?
Soll ich mich durchquälen? Soll ich mich durchquälen, ja?
Spiel einfach, was dir Spaß macht.
Dann würde ich jetzt wahrscheinlich, ähm, entweder Battlefield 3 spielen.
Bad Company 2 vielleicht?
Overwatch? Wobei mich der neue, der neue Mercy Patch,
den, nein, macht mir gerade keinen Spaß.
Unschlacht? Ja, ok, das können wir nochmal ausprobieren.
AI Control? Nein.
Starfighter Assault? Ja, ok, das probieren wir nochmal aus.
Mile to Battlefront macht mir keinen Spaß.
Ich bin seit drei Stunden, äh, seit zwei Stunden am Stream
und ich hatte nicht einmal Spaß in dem Spiel bisher.
Ich hätte doch bis jetzt schon öfters mal Hilton auswählen können.
Ich finde das auch nicht sinnvoll mit der, also mir gefällt das Konzept nicht.
Mit Battlepoints und dann OP Sachen anlocken und so.
Eine Runde sollte an sich für beide Seiten die gleichen Voraussetzungen bieten.
Das heißt nicht, dass es symmetrisch designt sein muss.
Man kann beide Seiten quasi ohne OP Sachen durch besseres Spielen
und taktischeres besseres Spielen, oder sagen wir insgesamt durch besseres Spielen,
eine Runde bei einem Game für sich entscheiden.
Nicht durch irgendwelche OP Klassen.
Klar, man kann jetzt sagen, ja, ok, wer ja besser spielt,
hat halt zuerst Held und gewinnt dann deswegen.
Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen abstrakt dann.
Woran es liegt, dass es keinen Spaß macht?
Wie gesagt, schwer zu beschreiben.
Es spielt sich irgendwie sehr, Moment.
Oh, ich glaube, das muss noch eine Joystick spielen.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich meine Joystick habe gerade.
Was zum Teufel?
Wie gibt man Gas?
Was geht hier wieder ab?
Oder ist es wie bei Battlefield, dass man ein bestimmtes Tempo halten muss?
Nee, hier nicht.
Wow.
Das ist die arcadigste und gleichzeitig schwammigste Weltraumschlag,
die ich je gespielt habe.
Da war Wing Commander 3 genauer.
Was machen meine Fähigkeiten?
Die Kamera ist fix, ja.
Was ist das?
Das ist der Ultralaser und das hier ist wahrscheinlich eine Rakete.
Warum sterbe ich einschneid?
Die Maus hängt.
Was?
War ich da dran, wirklich?
Oder darf man einfach nicht reinfliegen?
Nee, der Modus holt nicht alles raus.
Irgendwie geht das ganze Game irgendwie komisch, keine Ahnung.
Ich suche mal, ob man den Hangar reinfliegen kann, das wäre cool.
Was halt richtig geil wäre, warum kann man hier nicht reinfliegen,
aussteigen und dann da drin irgendwie Infanteriegefechte machen?
Das wäre doch mal was Cooles, oder?
Woops.
Okay.
Wir sind hier nicht bei Star Citizen.
Star Citizen hat ja sowas nicht gepachtet, dass es nur Star Citizen dürfte.
Das wäre doch mal cool.
Da könntest du mal ein ordentliches Objective passieren.
Stellt euch mal vor, wie geil man einen Rush-Modus machen könnte.
So nach dem Motto, startet hier vorne mit Raumschiffen,
man sprengt hier irgendwas rein, landet drinnen,
hat dann seinen neuen Spawn-Punkt drinnen,
muss dann hier 1, 2, 3 M kommen, sowas in die Richtung einnehmen.
Das wäre doch mal geil.
Wohohohoho.
Der Chip sackt.
Oh, der Typ ist weg.
Oh, der Typ ist gecrashed.
Wo musst du überhaupt hin?
Ja, hmm.
Oh.
Ich mach lick, dondown.
Okay.
Also 3000 Euro ist totaler Blödsinn. 3000 Euro muss keiner ausgeben für einen wirklich
sehr guten Gaming PC. Keiner. Total übertrieben. Wenn man sich ein bisschen anguckt, man kriegt
wirklich für 1000 Euro in dem Dreh, wenn man jetzt nicht ultra highend oder ganz oberstes
Segment haben will, ein Game mit dem man aktuelle Games gut spielen kann, kriegst du für 1000
Euro locker. Und wenn man wirklich ein highend Rechner haben will und schon Teile hat, dann
kann man ohne Probleme für 750 Euro aufrüsten. Ich meine neue CPU, Kühler ist dabei, neues
Mainboard, neue CPU und RAM. Mehr brauchst du ja nicht. Also ich hab ne neue Crate. Ne,
Mainboards sind nicht vorhanden. Grafikkarte ist vorhanden. Ich hab ein Gehäuse, meine
SSDs, Netzteil und die Grafikkarte. Also Preis-Leistungs... man braucht beim besten Willen keinen 3000
Euro PC, damit man aktuelle Games gut spielen kann. Das ist total overkill und Preis-Leistungsmäßig
extrem schlecht. Außerdem geh ich mal von aus, dass alle die du jetzt genannt hast wahrscheinlich
den PC nicht selbst gekauft haben, dass wegen Preis-Leistung keine Rolle gespielt hat. Ne,
also mal angenommen, ich mach jetzt doch mal demnächst was mit Alienware und die schicken
mir nen 4K PC, das war übrigens mal im Gespräch, nur kann ich jetzt ja mal nebenbei erzählen,
war im Gespräch sowas in dem Dreh. Natürlich hab ich auch nen 4K PC, das heißt aber nicht,
dass ich das dann für sinnvoll halten würde, mir von meinem eigenen Geld nen 4K PC zu kaufen
oder wenn ich ihr wär, würd ich mir keinen 4K PC kaufen. Die ganzen Sachen von Alienware,
von HP ist Omen und sowas und auch die ganzen Gaming-Geschichten von Asus. Man kann nicht
sagen, dass es schlecht ist. Früher hätt ich gesagt, null wer braucht Alienware. Es ist
nicht schlecht, Preis-Leistungsmäßig ist es halt nicht gut, aber für Leute, die sich
überhaupt nicht damit beschäftigen wollen, die auch nicht mal forum lesen wollen, was
gerade gut ist, was gerade schlecht ist, was gerade ne gute Kombination ist, die einfach
nur irgendwas kaufen wollen, was auf jeden Fall ordentlich Wumms hat, die können ohne
Probleme zu nem Alienware oder so greifen. Aber Preis-Leistungsmäßig fährst du definitiv
besser, wenn du dir was Sinnvolles selbst zusammenstellst, wenn du da die Fähigkeiten
zu hast. Ja und sag mal, wenn man das Alienware-Design jetzt gut findet und sagt, das ist einem
den Aufpreis wert und so viel, also wenn man es mal vergleicht, die Alienware-Dinger sind
mittlerweile, wenn man sich die richtige Kombination raussucht und auch die richtige Gerätekategorie,
die sind jetzt gar nicht mehr so extrem viel teurer, wie wenn man sich das selbst zusammenstellen
würde. Klar, immer noch, die müssen auch, von nichts kommt nichts, die müssen auch Geld
verdienen, aber das geht schon. Also Alienware ist ne Sache, die würd ich mir kaufen, hätt
ich keinen Bock, mich mit Technik zu beschäftigen. Ja Büffel, das reicht doch locker. Das reicht
sowas von locker. Du hättest auch nicht auf ne 1080 Ti aufrüsten müssen, deine 980 Ti,
ich hatt ja auch da vorne 980 Ti, das reicht locker. Predator Omen Alienware Razer, Preis-Leistungs-Mana
wegen keine Ahnung, müsste man sich mal angucken. Den besten Eindruck hat bisher, und wie gesagt
nicht gesponsert oder so von Alienware gerade, den besten Eindruck auf mich von den ganzen
Gaming Hardware macht immer noch Alienware. Bist du auf den Puppe-Hype aufgesprungen oder
lässt du das Gamelings liegen? Ich spiel's ein bisschen, selten, ab und zu, nebenbei,
der Battle-Royale-Hype, der erschließt sich mir nicht. Ich hab jetzt meine 980 Ti, hab
ich in meinen Server eingebaut und eine VM durchgereicht und hätte jetzt theoretisch
ne Villainous-VM mit richtiger Grafikkarte. Ich hab das nicht gemacht, weil's sinnvoll
ist, sondern weil's geht. Ich könnte jetzt quasi Plender auf meiner VM benutzen, oder
sowas. Oder irgendjemand könnte Remote auf meiner VM spielen. Das stimmt, irdische Ehre.
Wenn man nur Hearthstone spielt, braucht man keinen teuren Rechner. Blackfire LP, wenn's
dem Lost doch Spaß macht, und ich geh mal davon aus, beim Lost ist es auch nicht rein
nur, weil er das Game so wahnsinnig hypergeil findet, sondern weil's dann auch extrem gut
bei den Leuten ankommt. Das ist ja auch vollkommen legitim dann zu sagen. Ich hab jetzt was
gefunden, das gucken viele Leute. Wenn man hier sowas auf Twitch macht, ganz ehrlich,
jeder will ja, dass man ihn zuschaut. Das ist genauso wie auf YouTube. Wenn ich Videos
hochlade, will man natürlich auch, dass die geguckt werden. Und wenn er da was gefunden
hat, was ihm Spaß macht vom Spiel her, plus viele Leute ansprechen kann, ist das nicht
nur legitim, das ist vor allem auch vollkommen verständlich, dass er Puppe macht. Ja, manabing,
das kann gut sein. Niederlagen fühlen sich vor allem bei Puppe nicht so scheiße an,
weil du direkt weitercuen kannst. Pavilionman gefällt mir nicht. Ich hab jetzt zweieinhalb
Stunden gestreamt, nicht einmal Spaß gehabt in dem Game. Ja, Blackfire, ich denk mal,
das liegt auch einfach daran, dass viele Leute gerade auf ihn aufmerksam geworden sind wegen
Puppe. Und wenn er jetzt sagen würde, ich mach jetzt keinen Puppe mehr, dann gucken
ganz wenige Leute, was ja auch doof ist. Zumal er jetzt glaube ich sogar auch davon komplett
mittlerweile lebt und so was. Wär es blöd zu sagen, mach ich nicht mehr und hab 50%
oder 70% weniger Zuschauer. Das wär ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen blöd. Das Höllenmaschine
gewinnt Spiel. Ich hoffe, die haben diesmal nicht wieder Totenköpfe auf ihrem Rechner.
Max, was ist das letzte Game, das du gesuchtet hast, Overwatch? Tausend Stunden, über tausend
Stunden. Nee, ich spiel jetzt kein Puppe. Ich muss in eineinhalb Stunden zu meinen Dungeons
und Dragons Gruppe ins Discord und vorher muss ich noch was essen. Muss mich auch noch mal
kurz irgendwie ausruhen, ein paar Videos gucken, so zum Entspannen. GTA Roleplay? Ist das so
was wie Altes Life oder wie das hieß? So quasi so eine Art MMO. Aber Jesus, muss ich dir
recht geben. Sagen wir mal, so gut Puppe auch quasi vom Konzept her ist, dass es sich einfach
spannend spielt und halt auch recht zügig im Gameplay ist. Hat immer noch viele Durchhänger,
aber die Fights und generell Animationen und Feedback mäßig, wie sich das Game anfühlt,
finde ich auch scheiße. Da merkst du halt, das ist noch ziemlich roh, das Game. Das
was ich bisher, ich hab Fortnite nur von Streams gesehen, aber ich finde das sieht Fortnite
schon deutlich, also wirklich viel viel runder aus als Puppe in dieser Richtung. Aber gut,
das wird auch von Leuten gemacht, die damit schon länger Erfahrung haben. Was zum Teufel
ist GTA Roleplay? Ist das so was wie Altes Life oder wie das damals hieß? GTA Roleplay,
macht das der Krieger? Ich hab beim Krieger öfters gesehen, dass der GTA streamt. Ja,
Mana Wing, das wär was. Ich frage mich eh, warum gibt es im neuen, warum gibt es im neuen
Scott und für Battlefield noch kein Battle Royale Modus? So gut wie das ankommt, bring
es dann einfach mal raus. Machst du beim Hype mit? Ob das dann gut wird, ist was anderes,
aber das würde ihnen auf jeden Fall ein Spiel erbringen. H1Z1 hab ich mir gekauft auf Steam
und nie gespielt. Wollte ich damals mit dem Mesh spielen? Also damals gefragt hier, was
hältst du auf? Oder war unter der Max? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Ich glaub im Mesh
wollte ich das Spiel, hab ich aber nie gespielt. Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Follows.
Ich lese noch mal die letzten paar vor, weil ich sehe hier wieder mal nicht alle. Kinn
von Prazard, MWFanboy, Clockwork1989, der Allianz SpectreBFG, Entering Flavortown, erinnert mich
an, der Name erinnert mich an den Food Vlog Channel, den ich ab und zu auf YouTube gucke.
Troy, Lord Luke, BlackfireLP und wobei nicht, den hatten wir schon. Hutbeer, Hutbeer hatten
wir auf jeden Fall schon. Mehr seh ich nicht mehr. Scam ist gecrashed. Nice. GG. Dustinio,
danke für den Follow. Bist du morgen oder Sonntag wieder online? Ich bin wahrscheinlich
jeden Tag jetzt am Wochenende erstmal online, weil ich muss sagen, also mal gucken was es
für Games gibt, die man spielen kann. Mir macht das gestreme echt Bock, das ist super
entspannend. Ich setz mich hier hin, laber irgendein Scheiß, wir gucken 100 plus Leute
zu vom Scheiß labern. Und wer kann noch irgendwas bei spielen? Am besten was, was einem Spaß
macht, also nicht Battlefront. Und ich hab immer noch keinen Subbutton. Und ich hab
noch nicht mal bei Twitch gefragt. Ich will auch eigentlich gar nicht bis jetzt, weil
Subbutton verpflichtet so. Welche Serien schaust du momentan? Momentan gar keine. Ich wollte
mir mal Mr. Robot Staffel 2 angucken und so ein paar Sachen. Aber bin ich jetzt noch
nicht zugekommen und vor allem bei Mr. Robot Staffel 2. Ich hab mich da immer vor gedrückt
weiter zu gucken, weil ich die erste Staffel ziemlich geil fand. Eines der besten Serien,
die ich überhaupt geguckt hab, muss ich sagen. Bis halt auf das letzte, sagen wir mal, Drittel.
Das fand ich einfach scheiße. Da war ich echt so bei Mr. Robot war ich so ein bisschen
im Konflikt. So quasi zwei Drittel der Serie fand ich extrem geil und ein Drittel fand
ich ziemlich kacke. Deswegen hab ich überlebt. Vor allem das letzte Drittel. Wenn es das
erste Drittel gewesen wäre, hätte man immer noch sagen können, hey, das hat es jetzt
überwunden und wird jetzt richtig geil. Deswegen weiß ich schon, ob ich die zweite Staffel
gucken sollte. Ich fand halt an Mr. Robot geil, dass es irgendwo so einen Technikbezug
hatte, der nicht komplett aus der Luft gegriffen war. Also da wurde keine Cybernuke gestartet
oder sowas, wie in anderen Serien, sondern das war immer noch ein bisschen so geerdet,
so bei Mr. Robot. Die haben zwar manchmal auch Sachen ganz wild durcheinander geworfen.
Da gab es mal so einen Dialog. Was für einen Desktop hast du? Ich benutze GNOME. Ich habe
immer noch KDE. An sich passt der Dialog, aber auf der anderen Seite ergibt es auch
auf jeden Fall keinen Sinn. Außerdem ist die Zeit gestern Abend besser als hier Battlefront.
Andiversum. Ab und zu erwähne ich das mal, aber ich will das auf YouTube gar nicht so
sehr in Vordergrund stellen, dass ich jetzt auch auf Twitch streame, weil wir wissen
mittlerweile alle, auf YouTube gibt es viele Spasten. Bei mir hält sich das noch in Grenzen,
aber es gibt auch bei mir genug und ich habe die Hoffnung, wenn ich das nicht so sehr an
die große Glocke hänge, dass ich streame, dann bleiben die auf YouTube und lassen mich
hier in Ruhe. Sonst muss ich hier anfangen Leute zu bannen und sowas, da habe ich eigentlich
gar keinen Bock drauf.
Staffel 2 lohnt sich, ok. Ja, ich gucke mir das vielleicht nochmal an. Ok, jetzt ist 16.30.
Ich habe mir übrigens überlegt, beziehungsweise eigentlich war es die Idee von den anderen
Leuten aus meiner, oder was heißt aus meiner, es ist nicht meine Dungeons und Dragons Gruppe,
ich bin ja auch nur eingeladen dazu, das zu streamen. Wird euch das theoretisch interessieren?
Also ich meine heute Abend nicht, so mal für die Zukunft, nur mal für die Zukunft gefragt.
Wird euch das interessieren, wie ich da mit meinem Zwergen-Kläriker irgendwie Blö, Blödsinn
mache, weil ich nicht wirklich mich mit den Regeln auskenne. Ich haue zumindest überall
mit dem Hammer drauf. Und ich habe ein Schild, ich treffe die Mobs kaum, das habe ich auch
mittlerweile schon gemerkt. Und ich habe versucht zu schleichen, was nicht funktioniert hat.
Ich überlege mal, vielleicht können wir das ja bei einem der nächsten Runden machen.
Was ich mir überlegt habe, was so richtig nice wäre als Dungeons und Dragons Charakter,
als sagen wir mal einen Klärer, der quasi, muss man sich halt irgendwas ausdenken, oder
irgendeinen Typ, der so nicht mehr alle hat, und quasi tausende Stimmen im Kopf hört,
und halt die Stimmen werden dann quasi der Twitch-Chat. Und du müsstest random immer
irgendwas aus dem Twitch-Chat sagen. Naja, gut, also für alle, die es vielleicht interessiert,
sind immerhin immer noch 115 Leute dabei. Fazit zu dem Game, sieht gut aus, hat guten
Sound, hat gute Performance, aber ich hatte in zweieinhalb Stunden spielen keinen Spaß.
Was nicht heißt, dass ihr keinen Spaß haben könnt mit dem Game, aber ich hab zumindest
keinen. Ja, oh Jesus, das glaube ich dir bei dem Namen auch sofort, dass du dich trollen
würdest, sofort. Kennst du Pen & Paper von den Rocket Beans gesehen? Ich hab mal, ach
guck mal, der Wombo, ich hab mal einer der ersten Folgen ein bisschen geguckt.
Ist noch was krasses passieren? Nee, aber was jetzt passiert, was krasses, ich geh jetzt
auf und futter noch irgendwas. Wombo, wir sehen uns dann, spätestens in eineinhalb
Stunden. Also Leute, macht's gut, bis wahrscheinlich morgen, da müssen wir bloß mal gucken, was
wir für ein Spiel spielen. Vielleicht geben wir uns auch tatsächlich mal Overwatch ranked
wieder ne Runde, falls der Eax will, weil alleine vergrafen sich das nicht. Ja, macht's
gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss. Ja, Mr. Freiger, du bist leider zu spät. Tschüss.
Bye. Loll.
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Musik